Jennifer Washburn looks at the
relationship between corporate America
and higher education in her new book
University Inc she spoke recently at the
University of Maryland in College Park
this program runs 45 minutes good
afternoon it is first of all let me
welcome all of you to this afternoon's
talk by ms jennifer Washburn we are
honored and privileged to have you at
the University of Maryland campus rest
assured that the university commits none
of the bridges that you mentioned in any
of your publications so so we're even
more happy to have you with us also on a
personal note for me is a distinct honor
to introduce you as someone who studies
ethics in both the public and private
sector ms Washburn is a freelance
journalist and fellow at the new
American Foundation she's the author of
several books in articles her most
recent book is entitled university Inc
and she wrote an award-winning article
from the National Association of science
writers called the kept University
provocative titles of some before other
publications include selling out higher
education that tuition crunch and
digital diplomas ms Washburn scholarly
work and research focus on the growing
privatization of the public sphere
including the commercialization of
higher education a topic that I know is
near and dear to all of our hearts in
this room the reviews of University Inc
have characterized this publication as
the most important contribution to the
debate on the future of higher education
so congratulations again on this
contribution
some of the topics that she includes in
many of her publications include the
ethics controversies around publicly
funded scientists moonlighting as paid
consultants that manufacture the very
drugs that these companies are testing
and universities are on slippery slope
as they behave as research arms of some
of these private industries so without
further ado is my pleasure to welcome
you to the University of Maryland thank
you that was a very kind generous
introduction thank you well thanks to
all of you for coming out it's really
makes it much more fun to do these
events when lots of students and faculty
do come out because what what really
interests me is to is to really spark
discussion and of these issues so that's
really why I wrote the book so it's
great that you're here I thought I would
start by just reading a very short
section from the book just to give you a
little feel for what it reads like and
and then I'd sort of do a more more
overview kind of discussion of the
larger issues that I sort of take on in
the in the book so this comes from
chapter one on the afternoon of April 13
1999 a radiant spring day the Berkeley
campus hardly looked like the site of a
raging controversy Sproul Plaza was
bustling with activity students tossed
frisbees basked in the sun shine on lush
green lawns but inside room 60 of evans
hall where the lights were dim and the
atmosphere was tense and polarized there
are some two dozen faculty members
mostly professors in the College of
Natural Resources had gathered to hear
the disquieting results of a newly
released faculty survey the focus of the
survey was a controversial agreement
that Berkeley had signed in November
1998 with novartis a swiss-based
pharmaceutical giant and producer of
genetically engineered crops roughly two
years into the agreement Novartis
agricultural division merged with
another company
become syngenta despite this name change
however I'll continue to refer to the
collaboration as the Berkeley Novartis
alliance under the terms of the
agreement Novartis gave Berkeley 25
million dollars over five years to fund
basic research in the department of
plant and microbial biology one of four
departments within the College of
Natural Resources in exchange for the 25
million dollars berkeley granted
Novartis first rights to negotiate
licenses on roughly one third of the
department's discoveries including the
results of research funded by Novartis
as well as projects funded by state and
federal sources it also granted the
company unprecedented representation two
of five seats on the company's research
committee which determined how the money
would be spent that the university had
secured funding from a private company
was hardly unusual that a single
corporation would provide one-third of
the research budget for an entire
department at a public university had
sparked an uproar shortly after the
agreement was signed a newly formed
student graduate student group students
for Responsible research circulated a
petition blasting the agreement for
quote standing and direct conflict with
our mission as a public university the
daily californian Berkeley's student
newspaper published a five-part series
on the growing privatization of the
university and a coalition of public
interest groups sent a letter to
Berkeley's Chancellor Robert berdahl
charging that the alliance would quote
disqualify a leading intellectual Center
from the ranks of institutions able to
provide the kind of research free from
vested interest that is the hallmark of
academic life meanwhile Gordon rouser
the Dean of the College of Natural
Resources sent a message to all
professors urging them not to speak to
the press and to direct any questions
about the agreement to the university's
public relations office many viewed the
memo as a hush order we are here to
discuss the position of the faculty
Ignacio capela a professor of microbial
ecology announced at the April 13th
meeting chabela who was then serving as
the elected chairman of the college's
executive committee a faculty governing
body snapped on an overhead projector to
display the results of the survey the
novartis agreement has left the College
of Natural Resources
deeply divided he declared although
forty-one percent of the faculty
respondents supported the agreement as
signed more than 40 50 excuse me more
than fifty percent believed that it
would have a negative or strongly
negative effect on academic freedom
roughly half believed that the agreement
would erode Berkeley's commitment to
quote public good research and sixty
percent feared that it would impede the
free exchange of ideas among scientists
within the college one of chip Ella's
own concerns when I came to Berkeley
chabela explained to me after the
meeting the people who brought me here
were not were my closest colleagues
sorry the people who brought me here and
who were my closest colleagues were
largely in the department of plant and
microbial biology now I know that
anything I say to these people can be
turned around and handed over to
novartis so I just can't talk to them
anymore if I have a good idea i'm not
going to just give it away chappell
alike many critics of the deal is hardly
a confirmed opponent of university
industry relations before coming to
Berkeley he worked for none other than
Novartis then named Santos and afterward
he continued to have a relationship with
the company I'm not opposed to
individual professors serving as
consultants to industry he emphasized if
something goes wrong it's their
reputation that's at stake but this is
different this deal institutionalizes
the university's relationship with one
company whose interest is profit our
role should be to serve the public good
the Berkeley Novartis agreement was not
the first major alliance between a
prominent University and a private
corporation as early as 1974 Harvard
Medical School signed a 23 point five
million dollar agreement with Monsanto
to perform research on cancer tumors in
1983 Columbia University entered into a
multi-million dollar deal with
bristol-myers and there were many more
such deals that followed yet there's a
reason the Novartis agreement touched a
particularly raw nerve for too many
people in the academic world the
agreement seemed to mark the culmination
of a deeper transformation in which far
more was at stake than the fate of one
academic department the agreement came
at a time of mounting evidence that
commercial criteria were defining the
terms of academic life
sorry I've actually lost my place here
take for example the comments of
Professor J Patrick Kelly the Kmart
chair of marketing at Wayne State
University who told The Chronicle of
Higher Education kmarts attitude has
always been what did we get from you
this year some professors would say they
don't like that position but for me it's
kept me involved with a major retailer
and it's been good and it's been a good
thing at Berkeley it sill itself
buildings increasingly bored the names
of corporate donors industry-sponsored
research was ubiquitous and even
academic titles were changing with Laura
Dandrea Tyson a former top Clinton
advisor known as the bank america dean
of the Haas School of Business what's
more the Novartis agreement surfaced at
a time when whole new areas of public
life from schools to social services to
prisons were being privatized the public
sector appeared to be shrinking and was
possibly even becoming endangered if one
of the nation's preeminent public
universities was willing to lease out
its reputation and prestige in this way
where would other institutions draw the
line was it right to ask California
taxpayers to finance a higher education
system that effectively granted a
foreign a foreign-based multinational
monopoly control over its research such
concerns spilled well beyond for the
Berkeley campus to the Novartis Novartis
Berkeley deal can all too easily be
portrayed as an institution undermining
both its motivation and its trustworthy
worthiness to provide an independent and
impartial view of the most contentious
technologies of our time genetically
modified crops wrote the prestigious
science journal Nature in an editorial
titled is the university industrial
complex out of control I should have
made that clear that whole last quote
there the University the Novartis
Berkeley deal can all too easily be
portrayed as an institution undermining
both its motivation and trustworthiness
that all came from from this nature
editorial so I I didn't read that
terribly well but I hope that it it it
conveyed a little bit the flavor of sort
of what's happening on various different
university campuses the Novartis
Berkeley agreement was was the first
first sort of controversy on a
university campus that I tried to cover
and when I went there the faculty survey
had just been released and the campus
was really in an uproar and it really
prompted me to ask a number of questions
about what what is really happening to
these institutions and and and and so in
the rest of my talk I think I'll just
try to lay out a little bit what my
arguments are about what's going on
historically you know US universities
have always vigorously defended their
academic freedom and they've vigorously
fought to preserve their independence
from outside interest groups whether
they're religious political or
commercial what we've seen recently i
would say in the last 25 years is that
universities are drawing more and more
of their funding from private industry
since 1980 there's been an about an
eight percent increase in industry
support for academic research it's risen
about eight percent annually reaching
two billion in 2001 and the problem is
that this money comes with strings
attached increasingly industry is
requiring delays on publication there's
growing secrecy there are growing
proprietary restrictions on the research
and universities themselves are allowing
industry to control the raw data from
clinical trials so there's a there's an
extraordinary extent to which I industry
is able to manipulate and control the
terms of the research so how prevalent
is this problem there was a there was a
survey recently of 800 scientific papers
published in a range of bio medical
journals and it found that about
one-third of the authors had a
significant financial interest in their
own research when I say a significant
financial interest that could be
anything from holding a patent to the
drug that's being tested having equity
stakes in the company funding the
research or holding an executive
position in the company so the other
problem is it's not simply that
universities are drawing more of their
funding from industry but in fact that
universities them stealth themselves
starting to look and behave more like
commercial entities what what do I mean
by that well university is now research
universities throughout the country now
run their own industrial parks they run
their own venture capital funds they run
very extensive patenting and licensing
operations to commercialize their
research and license it to industry in
exchange for royalty income there's a
increasing the universities are
investing their own endowment money in
quite risky startup ventures that are
launched by their own professors there
was a very famous case at Boston
University where Boston University
invested about fifth events endowment
approximately 85 million dollars in a
startup company called ceragon that was
founded by its own professors the
university's president actually himself
invested in this he encouraged trustees
to invest in the company and finally
when the when the company's financial
situation deteriorated the the
university was accused of egregiously
mismanaging the university's endowment
in order to prop up the company so those
kinds of financial contract conflicts
are really unprecedented and it's a it's
a kind of commercial activity on the
part of the university that that is
significant so why is all this happening
well in my book I spend a lot of time
looking at the various different forces
that converged to to to to create this
situation but but here I'll just talk
about a few one is obviously cutbacks in
in public support for higher education
I'm sure a lot of people in this room
are quite aware of this most of the
state funded universities have have
experienced serious financial strain
since 1980 there has been the share of
state budgets that goes to fund higher
education has dropped by approximately
one-third at many many universities now
that used to receive about fifty percent
of their funding from the state now
receive only thirty percent or less the
University of Virginia remarkably
receives about eight percent of its
funding from the state of Virginia so
understandably
university administrators are feeling a
lot of financial squeeze so that's one
explanation the other explanation is
that in the 19 in the latter part of the
1970s the United States was experiencing
serious rising competition from Germany
and Japan we were facing a lot of
economic economic stagnation and the US
Congress decided to pass legislation
known as the bayh-dole Act it was named
after senators Birch Bayh and Bob Dole
this legislation although although many
of us don't know much about it is a
really important part of the book and I
try to give a very lively kind of
description of how it got passed because
it's fascinating the various different
forces that came together and and the
evidence on which it was based which by
the way it was very flimsy so the idea
of this legislation was essentially this
we're going to we're going to give
universities automatic rights automatic
intellectual property rights to
federally funded research and will allow
those universities to license that
research to private industry in exchange
for royalties the idea was that this
would encourage this would give
universities of financial incentive to
move academic research out of the
laboratory into the commercial
marketplace more quickly and it was
thought that this would spur innovation
so I you know a lot of people have been
singing the praises of the bayh-dole act
but but what but the bayh-dole Act never
really envisioned and it's remarkable
when you go back and look at the
hearings and and the the Congressional
hearings to see that there was
absolutely no attention paid to what
this might do to the University as an
institution so I've talked a bit about
how important the Independence of the
university is now the university had a
direct financial interest in its own
professors research and this is really
unprecedented us universities have long
had relationships with private industry
they've long had a role to play in
transferring academic inventions to
industry and all of this is a good thing
and and I certainly believe that
university should have collaborations
with the private sector but now you had
the university itself trying to profit
off of its own research and you and you
opened up
pandora's bat box so so what happened
essentially University started to try to
justify themselves to state legislators
and governors and the governors in turn
expected universities to serve as
engines of economic growth suddenly it
wasn't enough for the university to
teach the undergraduates it wasn't
enough for them to focus on training
top-notch scientists and and new world
leaders and teach people to think
creatively and independently it wasn't
enough for them to produce academic
research that would then be transferred
to industry and then be commercialized
the university itself was supposed to
play a more direct role in spinning off
startup companies generating high tech
jobs and literally creating the next
Silicon Valley in their own backyard
much as Stanford had been able to do and
MIT so there's a little bit of a
digression but when you actually look at
house to how Silicon Valley in route 128
got created turns out that the
university did not play a direct role in
in creating those high technology
centers around those universities yes it
was very important that they spun off
all of this incredible talent mostly in
the form of talented students and people
who left the university to start those
companies but but they didn't actually
play a direct commercial roll themselves
and now because because of this blurring
of the lines between commercial and
academic universities see it see it as
their role to to engage in these
commercial activities to to a degree
that we've not seen in the past so so
why is all this bad I mean we obviously
we want to see academic research
transfer to industry we want to see
companies benefit from that research and
so that we can all profit from the
products that they that they manufacture
the the the problem as I see it is
really threefold one is that it erodes
the university's capacity to serve the
public interest it confuses what the
role of the university is in our society
and we really have to ask we have to
really have to ask to what extent do we
want universities to be accountable to
the public or to the private interest
the conflicts of interest that I've
alluded to that that have arisen are
really very serious increasingly as we
there been a number of scandals that
we've all read about with with vioxx and
the various antidepressant drugs turns
out that academic scientists are stand
behind much of the research that brought
those drugs to the public in the past
academic investigators played a very
very important role in in performing
these clinical drug studies to make sure
that these drugs were safe and and to
perform that research independently of
the drug industry now increasingly
industry's hands are all over the
research and universities are not
defending their academic freedom enough
many university contracts allow the drug
companies to control the raw data from
these clinical trials that makes it very
very difficult for the academic
investigator to truly hold on to his own
autonomy and publish the research as as
he sees fit literally the drug company
can say well you don't have access to
the complete clinical trial data
therefore you can't say what the outcome
of this study was so professors are
becoming complicit by by signing their
names to research papers lending them an
aura of prestige a professor of Harvard
signs on to a drug study financed by
bristol-myers and there's no evidence
necessarily that bristol-myers lay
behind that study and yet that that
academic cannot actually vouch for the
research that that was that was finally
published this became such a problem
that various academic sorry various
medical journal editors have now come
out with very serious books critiquing
what's happening to medicine an academic
medicine in particular the editor of The
Lancet the British Medical Journal
actually went so far as to say that
academic medical journals have become
little more than money laundering
operations for the drug industry meaning
that the drug industry finances the
study but it's published under the name
of a prestigious academic it looks as if
it's been conducted independently but in
fact it's it's it's a foil for for the
drug industry's spin so so how does this
affect us even even the antidepressants
that
were recently pulled off the market it
turns out that academic scientists had
conducted a lot of the early original
research that had suggested that these
antidepressants were perfectly safe for
children and teenagers but when the FDA
went back and looked at the raw data
from those clinical trials they found
that it wasn't in fact consistent with
what these academics had published in
their own research then you go back and
you look at the academic scientists who
published those papers and you find out
that that nearly all of the lead authors
had very significant financial ties to
the antidepressant manufacturers so if
if the university becomes commercialized
in this way clearly we we lose one of
our centers of independent critical
thought in this country and that's
that's very troubling um I want to make
sure that we keep focused also this is
not just about the sciences this is also
really concerns students I think very
directly we've always had a problem in
this country that that universe there's
been a tension between research and
teaching but it's my argument that this
commercial commercialization of higher
education has has exacerbated this
problem what do I mean by that well at
the same time that universities are
pouring resources into these new
patenting and licensing offices many of
which are not not even profitable
they're actually eliminating full-time
professorships and increasingly relying
on part-time graduate students and
adjuncts to handle most of the
undergraduate instruction at the same
time that universities are charging
tuition higher price higher tuition
prices than ever before partly because
of cutbacks and state support you're
seeing that undergraduate education is
really undervalued the entire core
humanities disciplines are being
underfunded more and more the resources
of the university go to the fields the
subjects that make money study money or
attract money the salaries of professors
are increasingly tied to how much money
the faculty can actually bring into the
University in the past it certainly was
not the case that a salary levels were
relatively equal it was believed that
your salary should be based on
intellectual standing now increasingly
if you're a mathematician who won one of
the most prestigious prizes in the in
mathematics that the field the field
metal you might be paid the same salary
as as someone just a few years out of a
PhD in an economics department simply
because the economics department is a
more lucrative discipline so so to the
extent that university send out that
message that what matters what has value
is actually the almighty dollar and not
intellectual accomplishments that that
is a very disturbing trend and I think I
think it is bad for students I think it
sends entirely the wrong message that
universities have downsized teaching so
significantly the last thing and then I
want to open it up for questions and I
is is to just talk about what the effect
is on the US innovation system
interestingly the bayh-dole Act was
passed ostensibly to spur innovation but
increasingly and it's something that I
show in the book I interview various
different economists historians of
scientific innovation who are very
troubled by what's happening the
bayh-dole Act encouraged universities to
patent their research even when it was
very basic research and this is
troubling because often basic research
it's its greatest value is is is in its
ability to to spur new research it wants
to be free it wants to be broadly
available and when when universities
patent that research and license it
restrictive Lee they actually impede
innovation there's a really wonderful
example that's pretty telling from the
University of Utah when the University
of Utah a professor there discovered the
human gene that's responsible for
hereditary breast cancer the university
didn't make that research broadly
available as it as it would in the past
that research was funded with about 4.6
million dollars of taxpayer funding yet
the research yet the university licensed
the research exclusively to myriad
genetics which is a startup company that
was founded by the inventor and myriad
genetics then
proceeded to hoard the gene and prevent
other academic scientists throughout the
United States and throughout the world
from gaining access to it they charged
you know exorbitant fees to to access it
and essentially many many researchers
concluded they simply couldn't continue
their work on breast cancer research
because this critical hereditary this
gene responsible for registry breast
cancer had been patented so so we're
seeing really troubling developments
like that that happened with stem cells
it's happened with genetically modified
mice very basic building blocks of
science that are being privatized and
made proprietary in such a way that that
people who are concerned about the
pipeline for innovation believe that it
could stifle future innovation so to me
that's actually one of the most
troubling aspects of this because
universities historically have played a
critical role in defending the public
domain for knowledge they're their most
important function was to we always hear
about public aid publish or perish well
what does that what does that really
mean publisher perishes is about broad
dissemination of your research what has
value is too broadly is to make it
available to the public so when
universities start to treat their
research as if it was proprietary and
they don't understand the broader needs
of scientific advancement in the
innovation system that's deeply
troubling because this is the only area
where research is performed in a
non-proprietary way and even industry
experts are troubled by this and
interestingly I have a quote from the
Stanley Williams at hewlett-packard one
of their one of their top scientists who
recently testified before Congress
complaining that the bayh-dole Act has
made universities patent hungry and and
and overly overly aggressive and
basically hewlett-packard has now
decided that they might have to export
most of their basic research that they
used to fund they used to spend at us
universities they want to export it over
to Chinese universities and universities
in Europe why because they don't have
these aggressive patenting and licensing
provisions and hewlett-packard finds the
it's such an impediment to their being
able to use the research and actually
use it profitably in their own
commercial work that they don't want to
deal with us universities so when you
when you start to hear complaints like
that coming from industry I certainly
think that that's a wake-up call that
the bayh-dole act Mont might need to
seriously be modified so on all those
grounds I think giving you more than
enough to open some some discussion
thank you I know just going to ask and
see if anybody wants to plunge for the
first question yeah well it's it let me
just make a couple of remarks I've heard
around campus number one of course the
youth modern University their appetite
for funds is insatiable number two I
will quote a colleague of mine who once
pointed out that the basic difference
between this university and a brothel
isn't a brothel there were certain
things they won't do for money so do you
have any remedies for this yeah I I do
propose lots of remedies um um yeah it's
it's a University's we're getting a bad
rap from all sides and and I want to
make it clear III think there are most
vital institutions and so I i do have
recommendations but i think it's easy to
get so cynical that we don't even focus
on what what really needs to be fixed
here so i think that we need much more
stringent conflict of interest rules i
think that the federal government
recently the the nih decided that it
would impose much more stringent
conflict of interest rules on its own
scientists because they suddenly
discovered that their scientists were
off moonlighting as consultants for the
very drug companies that were
manufacturing the drugs that they study
at the NIH so what is the point of
having a taxpayer-funded independent
government agency that's supposed to be
serving the public interest that is in
fact moonlighting for the drug industry
on the side so so the NIH imposed
stricter conflict of interest rules they
banned that kind of outside consulting
and I think that it's only logical that
if a kid
emic investigators are receiving funding
from the federal government and from the
NIH they too should should have to
comply with much stricter conflict of
interest rules unfortunately every time
that that has come up as an issue it
came up in 1989 do two glaring conflicts
of interest at universities and it came
up again in early 2000 the university
establishment the university leadership
fought tooth and nail to to stop the
federal government from imposing
conflict of interest rules why because
they wanted to defend academic freedom
so I find it ironic that that the
university suddenly cry you know defense
of academic freedom when when when their
conflicts of interest have become so
pervasive what they argue is that they
want to be left to handle their conflict
of interest rules themselves but the
problem is the rules are so each
institution has its own rules and
there's a race to the bottom and
standards no one wants to impose tougher
rules than the other school because
they're afraid that the better
scientists and will leave two schools
that have loose or conflict of interest
rules so we really need a federal a
federal system of conflict of interest
rules that's that's one proposal among
many how often how often do you find
that you top researchers leave the
university because they don't want to be
restricting and just go to work for the
private company well you know
unfortunately I think what's happened is
that universities are are desperate to
you know in the past that if that might
have been a certain number of professors
may have decided to go into the private
sector but the universities would have
said okay then go you know perhaps you
you might come back at a future time but
now they're trying to have it both ways
the professor is becoming a professor
entrepreneur he has his startup company
on the side he he's very heavily
involved in that company he's also
trying to teach graduate students in my
book I have some incredible examples of
graduate students at Stanford University
who left to two very very talented
students who had been had received all
kinds of
honors and accolades who literally left
their professors lab because they felt
that he was he was so conflicted he his
his commercial interests in his own
company were compromising their own
ability to finish their PhDs literally
some of their research migrated over to
the company without their knowledge and
they were very upset about it and the
university did not respond in my view
from my research and investigations of
the case they did not respond adequately
so so suddenly these students PhD
research wound up in a company
presentation that was being showed to
investors at the professor's startup
company without their knowledge and that
was unpublished research it hadn't been
verified and it was researched that they
had hoped to publish as part of their
academic studies so these kinds of
conflicts are arising all over the place
because the it's it becomes increasingly
difficult to determine who owns the
research that's being performed in these
academic labs you know by increasing
fights between faculty and universities
and students over the right to
commercially valuable inventions there's
an amazing case at the University of
South Florida where the university
actually filed suit against a master's
student Peter DeBoer ski who discovered
a promising way to remove ammonia from
wastewater commercially promising way to
do that and both the University and the
company that had been sponsoring the
professor's lab essentially filed suit
against him he was accused of stealing
University property and literally the
case became such an embarrassment that
the the governor of the the state of
Florida had to intervene and and grant
him clemency so these kinds of these
kinds of this is unprecedented we
haven't seen that kind of that kind of
commercial battles going on in
universities but but I think we really
need to think through perhaps if if
faculty do have research that they
absolutely need to be involved in
commercially in order to bring it to
commercial fruition then they should be
able to take an extended sabbatical away
from school but they there shouldn't be
this bleeding of academic and commercial
activities that were seeing today
what does the university administration
was more strapped for cash due to to get
the funds necessary yeah I mean I think
it's it's a it's a really complicated
question I mean I think this goes back
to your your point that you know it is
also a question of what the university's
priorities are you know is it necessary
to have a movie theater on campus for
the students is it necessary I mean
maybe you guys love it maybe it's great
but there are certain questions of
priorities how how fancy and elaborate
does that does the campus gym have to be
you know where where is the university
putting its money and what what are its
real priorities is it to pay full-time
teachers to teach undergraduates or is
it to finance these patenting and
licensing offices that as I as I show in
my book the vast majority of the
university patenting and licensing
activities are barely breaking even so
they're pouring money into this activity
to justify themselves to state
legislators into governor's to show that
they have commercial that they're doing
something that's good for business but
in fact that most of these patenting and
licensing operations are not moneymakers
so you know but they're pouring money
into hiring these patent lawyers it's
they're very expensive operations and
and so a lot of it is a question of
priorities too and I think that
universities have to do a better job of
going to their legislators and
explaining what they have traditionally
done so well and why those traditional
functions are being jeopardized by this
increasing pressure to grow more
commercialized if they if they if they
don't defend the core the core functions
that they perform and and justify those
to the legislature you know then I think
I think that there that they're they're
going to lose that they're going to lose
the battle to to persuade the
legislature why it is that a public
university does need to be publicly
funded
any other questions from students her
yeah sorry i'll take you women used well
i'm going to book this subject that
dealt with research into a heart
medicine and the the company it was
doing this i had an interest in getting
the medicine out of the market because
they gonna make a huge amount of money
since then have any competition for us
but it turns out that people were dying
as a result using this medicine and
there the research wasn't being done the
show that the medicine was killing
people it wasn't helping to keep them
alive so I this this is a kind of
lethality that can get involved here
yeah cuz you don't have somebody who
says well I want to find out
I think that and you get people in the
university who are employed you know by
the company and working the university
the bear their allegiances to the
company because the company is paying
them so much money right right no I you
know you're absolutely right i mean it's
it's hard to understate the the
significance i mean when medical
research is commercially driven there's
bury it can have profoundly dangerous
effects for human health you know people
take these drugs and they depend on them
and they're sick and you know there's
there's an incredible case at the
University of Pennsylvania when when
this young man died in a gene therapy
experiment at the University of
Pennsylvania you know that the father
was completely distraught the this young
man had volunteered altruistically for
this clinical trial at the university to
test a very it was a very rare liver
disorder and I'm forgetting the the
exact name of it at the moment but
essentially the the it turned out that
the university university and the lead
investigator had a financial interest in
the in the clinical drug study and that
only came to light after the FDA started
investigating his death and also
discovered that the university had
egregiously violated a number of the
federal rules designed to protect human
subjects I mean enormous discrepancies
and violations of federal rules to
protect human subjects so you know we
can't we can't prove that the University
scientists shirked their their
scientific duty to protect the patients
because of their financial interests but
certainly it did not look good and it
raises questions about whether they
might have you know done more shoddy
research because they they were so eager
to show that the drug was successful
that they didn't actually take taken in
consideration how the patient was
actually doing and so those kinds of
financial conflicts can have life life
financial conflicts of interest can have
light
and death consequences I'm just going to
ask yeah you how much do you think
textbooks are being affected textbooks
you know I know that that's a huge area
I certainly I know that textbook prices
have gone up enormously i think i think
i recently read something that they've
gone up about sixty percent in the last
decade or so i I'm sure that you
probably it sounds like you probably
know more about this than I do do you is
that are there are there issues coming
up in the textbook wrong my mommy
medical stuff and I I just see stuff is
a little surprising that works rigor and
not what's suppressed and what
selectively it was left out yeah you
mean Google some tough people then come
forward to come forward mm-hmm as I see
there's energy going into controlling
what's in our free press say yeah for
your well i think you know it's it's a
it's quite clear there there are a
number of there's a lot of research now
that shows that when industry when
research is industry-funded it is
significantly more likely to reach
conclusions that favor the industry's
interests then research that's
non-profit funded or government funded
so that that bias is is there I mean and
we're and we're seeing very very serious
suppression of academic research as well
we've had cases where an AIDS researcher
at the University of California at San
Francisco tried to publish research on
an on an AIDS drug showing that the AIDS
drug was no more effective than a
placebo and he was slapped with a with a
seven to ten million dollar lawsuit by
the corporate sponsor and the university
had to deal with that so there there are
very overt forms of suppression of
research going on but also much much
much more subtle versions yeah well I
think an interesting area
has to do with NIH I think back in 1973
they decided out there but in the
National Institute of Mental Health that
they would no longer consider
homosexuality to be psychopathological
and that they would have the Diagnostic
and Statistical Manual change so that it
would not list homosexuality as a
psychopathological nor just take it out
of it and however it is like
pathological and it's an area where you
don't have to deal with the jeans
because it's not genetic so it's not a
medical problem it doesn't derive from
there are chains like my mouth
well then along came the AIDS crisis no
and all of this stuff about how well we
gotta have you know wide open society
but but you know this is an area where I
think some attention needs to be spent
and it's not you know a strictly medical
area but it's a social psychological and
if you don't deal with it things things
are getting worse d the aids for
instance seems to be metamorphosed into
it you know a worse form of AIDS I'm not
totally clear what this has to do that
with the commercial sort of aspect of it
well if you're going to say yeah but I
mean if you're going to say that there's
there's nothing wrong but these people
are just doing their thing and it's
equal or equivalent to somebody else's
behavior now and you're not going to pay
any attention to it then what you're
doing is you're really encouraging that
the medical pathology was mated to AIDS
you encouraging this the social
pathology I mean you want somebody I'm
just gonna I'm gonna cut you off up
sorry but I mean I I think that's it's
obviously a huge huge issue but but not
not really related to this at hand but I
listen I think there's there's many
there's many things we could talk about
on that on that front but yeah let's get
back to this business now you said very
correctly that when the university goes
to the state to ask for some money there
their argument is basically a hundred
percent economic growth now what they
mean by that is is is not so much the
things you're talking about but but
they're training people in IT or
training technical people more or less
they pay lip service to Liberal Arts and
the idea of quote an educated citizenry
but they don't really believe it right
and they and and this is why you see
that that certain fields are paid more
than other
yeah yeah no I think there is a huge the
humanities are really are really
struggling to to hold hold their own in
this in this increasingly this
atmosphere where we're increasingly
students are treated like consumers and
research is a product and everybody
wants to know what the economic dividend
is because if you're just looking at for
a short-term economic dividend the
humanities are always going to lose out
but I actually have a wonderful quote
from the from the federal reserve
chairman Greenspan who who who just has
the most eloquent defense of a liberal
arts education and I put it in the book
but you know he spoke about the fact
that increasingly what we need in in
this new information driven economy more
than anything is is is for students to
be able to think critically and
creatively and to to be able to to
express themselves and and that where r
where r true competitive edge is going
to lies is is in our intellectual
faculties and certainly he talks very
very eloquently about how the humanities
have traditionally done in a remarkably
good job of stimulating that kind of
critical thinking and creativity of
thought and so if we you know I think
that is sort of the the bigger message
maybe I'll end on this that the bigger
message of the book is that sometimes we
don't realize where the true economic
value of our of our education lies I
interviewed the one of the founders of
the biotechnology revolution a man named
Paul Berg at Stanford who spoke about
the fact that when when they were doing
all the initial research that led to the
biotechnology revolution the venture
capitalists weren't interested in it
nobody in industry was interested in in
it it didn't seem to have any commercial
value at the time it seemed to be very
very abstract a sort of curiosity-driven
research that had no commercial utility
and then lo and behold it gave birth to
the biotechnology revolution and so he
expresses real concern about whether or
not if the university becomes
commercially oriented whether whether it
will be able to support the kind of
basic curiosity-driven research
that will drive the next biotechnology
revolution and and so we must be careful
not to not to down downplay the
significance of this independent
academic sphere that is not driven by
commercial forces because it's all of
those those areas that that are likely
to give fruit in unexpected ways so
thank you so much Jennifer washburn has
written for Atlantic Monthly the
Washington Post and the nation
University Inc is published by basic
books online at basic books com mona
chair